the reason Costco has done food samples
for such a long time is that it drove
sales they knew that giving away free
food and paying people to sit there
giving away toothpicks of stuff sold
more product they're not idiots let's
say you try all the things at Costco
sampling which many people do you tried
20 things but one of them you really
liked you're like man this bean dip
seven layer bean dip is not that bad
what do you do you buy one what would
you have not done if you hadn't done it
you wouldn't have bought it all together
if they had offered none of those so the
cost of all those samples is the cost of
delivering the lead magnet but they make
it up and some in you buying the thing